.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ist weniger mehr für ein gutes Leben?
Was denken Sie?
Anstatt noch mehr zu verdienen,
noch mehr Besitz anzuhäufen
und sich noch mehr reinzuziehen,
bewusst Nein zu sagen?
Auf die Frage suche ich eine Antwort:
Macht Verzicht glücklich?
Ich treffe Tina Schmidt,
die auf Sex verzichtet hat ...
Das bin z.B. ich.
Das war auch als Cover
auf dem "kult!"-Magazin.
Das Leben
stimmte für mich einfach nicht mehr.
... Carla Opetnik, die keinen Abfall
produzieren will ...
Das ist ein Wurmkompost.
Da bewegt es sich.
Das Ziel ist, dass nichts
aus deiner Lebenszeit zurückbleibt.
... Sandra Buchser,
die auf jeglichen Komfort verzichtet
und darum in einer Jurte lebt ...
Wenn du verzichtest,
kommst du wieder in Bewegung.
Es wird ja unbequem.
... Daniel Hellemann,
der sich konsequent Social Media
und allem, was ihn ablenkt,
entzieht ...
Hier habe ich das Handy weggeworfen.
Champagner? Nein, danke.
- Oder Weisswein.
Sagt, was ihr wollt.
... und Hausi Leutenegger,
der schon als Junge
auf so viel verzichten musste,
dass er später
lieber aufs Verzichten verzichtet.
Bei unserer Generation,
als ich zur Welt kam, hiess es:
"Vogel friss oder stirb."
Die erste Person, die ich treffe,
ist Cédric Waldburger.
Guten Morgen.
- Freut mich, ich bin Mona.
Freut mich.
- Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Willkommen in Pfäffikon.
- Hast du schon auf etwas verzichtet?
Ich habe nicht gefrühstückt.
Das ist aber kein Verzicht,
weil ich selten frühstücke.
Ich bringe aber Gipfeli mit,
daher frühstücken wir
vielleicht etwas später.
Weil ich im Verzichten
sicher weniger geübt bin als du?
Oder du
frühstückst einfach lieber als ich.
Es gibt fast keine bessere Person
als dich,
um die Sendung "Macht Verzicht
glücklich?" zu eröffnen.
Du beschäftigst dich
schon lange mit dem Thema,
was eigentlich glücklich macht.
Cédric Waldburger hat sein Glück
im Minimalismus gefunden.
* Piepsen *
(Roboterstimme) 16 push-ups to go.
Jeden Morgen macht er Push-ups.
Er ist nie länger als drei Nächte
an einem Ort.
Und er duscht ausschliesslich kalt.
Weil er beruflich viel unterwegs ist,
hat er seine Wohnung aufgegeben.
Er schläft
im Hotel oder bei Freunden.
Er besitzt nur noch 64 Gegenstände.
Cédric Waldburger ist Minimalist.
Das ist alles Materielle,
das ich besitze.
Nebst dem Bankkonto.
Bankkonten und auch Firmen,
verschiedene Projekte -
davon besitzt man ja auch Anteile.
Aber alles,
was man berühren kann ...
... liegt auf dem Bett
oder trage ich.
Es ist alles komplett schwarz.
Das hat verschiedene Vorteile:
Es passt immer alles zusammen.
Ich muss
nur einmal pro Woche waschen.
Ich muss auch
eine Entscheidung weniger treffen.
Entscheide ich mich dazu,
etwas zu kaufen,
muss ich nicht überlegen, ob ich es
in Rot, Schwarz oder Blau kaufe.
Und der letzte Punkt ...
... ist etwas Praktisches:
Die Betten in Hotels und Apartments
sind meistens weiss bezogen.
Es ist schwieriger,
etwas Schwarzes darauf zu verlieren
als ein weisses T-Shirt oder Hemd.
Für Cédric Waldburger
ist das derzeit alles,
was er an Besitz braucht.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Minimalist Waldburger
entwickelt Apps,
um sein Leben und das aller anderen
zu optimieren.
Er ist international an verschiedenen
Firmen und Projekten beteiligt.
Darum ist er ständig unterwegs.
Sein Büro ist jeweils dort,
wo es Internet gibt.
Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Jetzt boardet gleich mein Flug.
Es geht nach Singapur.
Es geht nach Frankfurt.
Es geht nach Indien
und dann weiter nach Australien.
Gut 1,5-mal um die Erde
in drei Wochen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Jetzt bin ich am Flughafen Zürich.
Ich habe eine App,
mit der ich einchecken kann.
Flughafen Zürich. Und ...
... da sieht man:
Innerhalb der letzten paar Jahre
ist es
mein 255. Mal am Flughafen Zürich.
Für die digitalen Nomad:innen
ist es normal geworden,
zwischen den Welten,
in denen die einen an Mangel leiden
und die anderen den Überfluss
beklagen, hin- und herzupendeln.
Immer im Fokus: die stete Steigerung
der Lebensqualität.
Cédric Waldburger will v.a. die beste
Version seiner selbst sein.
Heute wachte er
in einem Hotel in Armenien auf,
in Jerewan.
Can you go through the expectations
we collected
at the beginning of the retreat?
Er gibt Anweisungen an sein Team,
das er gleich trifft.
Wie immer
hat er seinen ganzen Besitz bei sich.
Viermal im Jahr trifft er sein Team
irgendwo auf der Welt -
es sind inzwischen
sieben Mitarbeiter:innen -
jeweils
in einem sog. Co-Working-Space,
einem gemieteten Büro.
Namaste, guys.
Morning, guys.
- Morning.
Online hat er als Chef
jederzeit die Übersicht darüber,
woran seine Angestellten
gerade arbeiten.
Bezahlt
wird nur sog. produktive Zeit.
Auch in seinen Firmen
geht es v.a. um Effizienzsteigerung.
These will be the emails
triggered from the mixed panel.
Sein persönlicher Assistent Bojan
lebt in Moldawien
und organisiert von dort aus
das Leben seines Chefs.
Auch ihn
trifft er nur alle drei Monate.
Ich mag die Idee ...
... alles minimalistisch zu halten.
Man ist auch sehr mobil, was für
seinen Lebensstil sehr wichtig ist.
Und ja, ich finde das
ziemlich interessant.
Sie haben eine Familie:
Könnten Sie sich das auch vorstellen?
Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Mit Kindern geht das nicht.
Waldburger besitzt natürlich
auch kein Auto mehr.
Sein bester Freund Fabian Villiger
hingegen schon.
Mit ihm fährt er gerne mit.
Merci.
- Bitte.
Sieht man sich Cédrics Lebensstil
jetzt an -
64 Dinge, minimalistisch,
aufs Wesentliche beschränkt -
ist das superschön.
In ein paar Jahren
möchte er vielleicht eine Familie
und es gibt ein, zwei Kinder.
Dann schauen wir,
wie viele Spielsachen sie haben.
Die sagen nicht,
dass sie ein Auto wegwerfen müssten,
wenn sie ein anderes wollen,
weil das nicht mehr
auf der Gegenstandliste steht.
Das ist schon nicht so einfach.
Was ich diszipliniert durchziehen
will, ist immer konsequent zu sein.
Zu fragen, was mich glücklich macht
und das zu verfolgen.
Momentan heisst das,
viel Zeit mit verschiedenen
Projekten zu verbringen,
möglichst frei zu sein,
von einem Tag auf den nächsten
den Kontinent wechseln zu können.
Darum habe ich so wenige Dinge.
Weil das einem Ziel dient,
das mich glücklich macht.
Im Moment fühlt er sich
sehr gesund und lebendig.
Er hat sich verliebt.
Seine Freundin
wartet heute in Berlin auf ihn.
Schönen Tag.
Im Gegensatz zu Cédric hat sie aller-
dings eine Wohnung in der Schweiz.
Na du?
Hi.
Auch sie ist als digitale Nomadin
oft unterwegs.
Selbstoptimierung
entspricht auch ihr.
Ihre Arbeitsstile passen zusammen.
Sie optimiert Suchmaschinen.
Elena hat allerdings allein in
ihrem Badezimmer mehr Dinge stehen,
als ihr Freund im Ganzen besitzt.
Es gab von Anfang an eine Regel:
Wenn wir zusammen reisen ...
Manchmal kommt Elena mit
oder ich gehe dorthin, wo sie ist,
oder wir fliegen
zusammen aus der Schweiz.
Ich sagte, dass wir das nur
mit Handgepäck machen würden.
Ich verschwende keine Zeit
mit Warten an der Gepäckausgabe.
* Entspannte Musik *
Wenn man sich den Film ansieht,
finde ich das sehr extrem,
wie du das machst.
Was ist eigentlich das Ziel?
Was suchst du,
wenn du dich so reduzierst?
Ich habe die Freiheit gesucht, sehr
konsequent entscheiden zu können,
was Ballast ist und in was ich meine
Zeit und Energie investieren möchte.
Ich musste eine extreme Version
wählen.- Warum?
Weil ich so verstehen konnte,
was ich wirklich brauche.
Da ich zuerst
einen grossen Teil losgeworden war,
alles bis auf die damals 64 Sachen,
spürte ich sehr klar,
was wirklich essenziell ist.
Und noch ein Grund:
Ich wollte Zeit mit den Leuten
und Projekten verbringen,
die mir wichtig sind.
Nichts anderes.
Ich musste mich um kein Auto
und keine Wohnung kümmern.
Darum liess ich alles los,
um mich darauf zu konzentrieren.
Wir haben gesehen, dass du beim Flie-
gen gar nicht minimalistisch bist.
Das ist krass.
Wenn man sich
mit CO2-Ausstoss beschäftigt,
würde man sagen:
"Da muss man hinschauen."
Ist das kein Widerspruch?
Einerseits bist du so reduziert,
aber da überbordest du.
Es war eine sehr intensive Zeit,
was das Reisen anging.
Teilweise über 100 Flüge pro Jahr.
Das kam Hand in Hand
mit viel Negativem: Jetlag, CO2 usw.
Ich habe es aber gemacht,
weil es extrem viele spannende
und wichtige Erfahrungen brachte,
die ich nicht missen möchte.
Ich musste entscheiden,
ob ich das machen möchte.
In diesem Falle ergab das Sinn.
Ich überdenke das
aber auch regelmässig.
Ich reise momentan weniger.
- Ja gut, Corona.
Damit kam plötzlich
ein unfreiwilliger Verzicht.
Wie viel Mühe hattest du damit,
nicht mehr zu dürfen?
Corona kam für mich
zur richtigen Zeit.
Meine Frau und ich wurden
ein, zwei Monate vorher schwanger.
Darum veränderte sich eh viel.
Viele Projekte, die vorher viel
physisches Zusammensitzen brauchten,
sind jetzt erwachsener
und viel Kommunikation
findet jetzt eh über Video statt.
Man hört, dass sich in Cédrics Leben
einiges verändert hat.
Du bist Vater geworden.
Wir wollen schauen,
ob man Minimalist sein und
gleichzeitig eine Familie haben kann.
Schauen wir ...
- ... wie dein neues Leben aussieht.
Ist es die oben?
- Die erste mit der Terrasse.
Hallo, Fräulein. Hallo.
Hoi. Hoi.
Mäuschen.
Das ist Mona. Elena.
- Freut mich.
Hi, freut mich.
- Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Und Lana. Lana Happy.
- Hoi, Lana.
Wirklich?
- Ihr zweiter Name ist Happy.
Nein.
- Sie macht ihrem Namen alle Ehre.
Lana Happy.
- Sie ist sehr oft happy.
Es hat sich viel verändert
in deinem Leben.
Wir haben dich vor dreieinhalb
oder viereinhalb Jahren
das letzte Mal getroffen.
Damals hattest du
nicht mal eine eigene Wohnung.
Jetzt hast du eine Wohnung,
eine Frau, ein Kind ...
Ich bin gespannt.
Darf ich mich etwas umschauen?- Ja.
Da steht ein leeres Gestell. Habt ihr
nichts, das ihr reinstellen könntet?
Ähm ...
Nein. Ich wüsste nicht,
was ich da hinpacken sollte.
Was hast du alles mitgebracht?
Die ganzen Möbel sind von mir.
Ich hatte vorher auch eine Wohnung.
Cédi hat eigentlich
seine Tasche mitgebracht.
Er war wirklich
in 30 Sek. eingezogen.
Er kam
mit dem Rucksack durch die Türe
und dann war er da.
Du hattest etwas mehr -
zwei, drei Kisten.
Nein, nein, ich hatte vorher
wirklich eine richtige Wohnung
mit sehr vielen Sachen.
Bevor wir hierhergekommen sind,
habe ich sehr viel aussortiert.
Hast du eine Mulde gefüllt ...
- Ja.
... mit deinen Sachen?
- Definitiv. Ja.
Ist das das Wohnzimmer?
- Ja.
Das ist Lanas Zimmer.
Kann es sein, dass jemand wie Cédric
ein bisschen abfärbt?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe es
nicht einfach so gemacht.
Ich kam immer mehr ins Denken
und habe immer mehr gesehen,
wie schön das auch für mich ist
und wie gut das passt.
Er hat mich nie dazu gezwungen.
Es war nie so, dass er gesagt hätte,
weniger sei besser.
Wir haben uns irgendwann
zusammengesetzt und überlegt,
welche Sachen
uns im Leben wichtig sind.
Und wie können wir alles andere,
das so drumherum ist, eliminieren?
Gehst du zu Mami?
- Ja.
Wir können uns den Rest ansehen.
Hier ist das Wohnzimmer.
Es ist schon ...
Ich möchte nicht kahl sagen.
Ungemütlich, oder?
- Ja, also ... Hm ...
Das hast du gesagt.
Es ist nicht so heimelig.
Das kommt von damals, als wir
sehr wenig Zeit hier verbrachten.
Das Praktische stand im Vordergrund.
Fabian, dein Freund, sagte ja ...
- Ja.
... du seist so lange Minimalist,
bis du ein Kind und eine Frau hast.
Es gibt zwei Dinge:
Das eine ist der Minimalismus.
Ich mag den Begriff nicht,
weil das heisst, weniger sei besser.
Es geht mir nicht darum.
Ich finde die Begriffe Essenzialist
oder Wesentliches spannend.
Ich will nicht unbedingt
mehr oder extrem viele Sachen haben,
aber etwas wie eine gemütliche Couch
gibt uns viel Wert,
darum möchten wir die haben.
Das möchte ich Lana
relativ früh im Leben weitergeben.
Sie soll all die Spielsachen haben,
die sie begeistern und faszinieren.
Aber ich bin gespannt darauf,
wenn sie das erste Mal sagen kann:
"Wenn ich etwas Neues kriege,
gebe ich etwas anderes weg."
"Was gebe ich weg
und an wen verschenke ich das?"
Wie gut sich das anfühlt,
habe ich relativ spät erfahren.
Hey Google: turn the lights on.
Mal schauen, ob er es kapiert.
(Mann) Hoi, Cédric.
- Hello. Hey, Claude.
Hello.
- Mit Formeln im Hintergrund?
Ja. I'd say: let's get started.
I'll let everyone in
in a few seconds.
(Cédric auf Englisch)
For anyone joining from Singapore.
In those sessions in groups of five,
six or seven participants ...
So.
Dann darf ich wieder rausspringen.
Wie minimalistisch bist du mit Geld?
Geld ist eine wichtige Ressource,
um das umsetzen zu können,
was ich möchte.
Es braucht Geld, um Firmen
zu starten und zu experimentieren.
In meinem Business
scheitern neun von zehn Ideen.
Ich brauche also Ressourcen.
Aber ich richte meine Lebens-
entscheidungen nicht danach aus,
was mir kurzfristig
am meisten Geld bringt.
Wenn ich mich hier umsehe,
sehe ich auch bei den Möbeln ...
Dein Laufband
ist wahrscheinlich das Teuerste.
Du gibst kein Geld
für sinnliche Dinge oder Genuss aus.
Für Erlebnisse schon:
für Reisen, um etwas mit Freunden
oder mit der Familie zu erleben.
Das sieht man hier halt nicht.
Davon nehmen wir
ein Foto oder so mit.
Es geht mir darum,
dass wir die Zeit geniessen können
und voll im Moment sind.
Kannst du wirklich geniessen?
- Ja. Ja, ja.
Kommt das nicht so rüber?
- Nein.
Wirke ich so ...
Du lebst schon sehr in Schwarz
und Weiss, würde ich sagen.
In vielen Lebensbereichen ja.
Da bin ich etwas speziell.
Mein Kopf fühlt sich wohl,
wenn die Wände weiss sind.
Null und Eins, das bist du.
- Ja, sehr binär.
Ja.
Wo schaltet man die ein? Ah, so.
Das ist der zweite Kaffee,
den ich mit dieser Maschine mache.
Wem gehört die denn?
- Meinen Eltern.
Sie kümmern sich manchmal
hier um Lana.
Sie sagten,
sie bräuchten eine Kaffeemaschine,
wenn sie mal einen Abend
oder einen Tag hier sind.
So kam die Kaffeemaschine zu uns.
* Rattern *
Macht der Verzicht ...
... glücklich?
Mich macht ...
... der Verzicht in den Bereichen,
wo ich ihn lebe, sehr glücklich.
Das gibt mir viel Ruhe.
Wie geht euer Leben weiter?
Werdet ihr wieder reisen?
Werdet ihr wieder digitale
Nomad:innen oder wie sieht das aus?
Wir gehen vom Weltenbummeln
ins Reihen-Eck-Einfamilienhaus.
Sicher?
Das ist auch
ein bisschen sinnbildlich dafür ...
... wie viele Sachen
in meinem Leben laufen.
Man muss auch
Spass mit dem Ganzen haben.
Viele Leute nehmen mich
als Minimalisten wahr.
Aber ich beschreibe mich
nie als Minimalisten,
weil das ein kleiner Teil davon ist,
wie ich mich sehe.
Der grössere Teil ist,
dass ich immer Freude
an Experimenten haben werde.
Ich wünsche euch alles Gute.
Danke für den Einblick.
Gerne.
Im Vergleich zu der Frau,
die wir jetzt kennenlernen,
lebst du schon im Luxus.
Ich muss es so sagen.
Sandra Buchser
hat sich dazu entschieden,
auf jeglichen Wohnkomfort
zu verzichten.
Was sie sich davon erhofft,
sehen wir uns jetzt an.
Ich muss Holz holen.
Büsi, geh weg da.
Verzicht
ist in erster Linie unbequem.
Dort ist der Ursprung.
Unser Leben ist zu bequem.
Man kommt nach Hause
und hat einfach alles.
Es war mir etwas langweilig,
kann man sagen.
In der Wohnung zu sein, arbeiten
zu gehen - es fehlte mir etwas.
Ich möchte mich mit etwas
beschäftigen, das mich interessiert:
im Garten arbeiten,
draussen sein ...
... in Symbiose mit der Natur
und den Jahreszeiten leben.
Ah, jetzt reicht's.
Bald sehe ich aus wie Shila. Komm.
Ich wollte mich
mit etwas beschäftigen,
das mich interessiert.
Also ging ich auf die Suche.
Ich wanderte
einfach durch die Schweiz
und schaute, was für alternative
Wohnformen es überhaupt gibt.
Ich schaute mir v.a. Landwirtschaft,
Kräuterbauern usw. an.
Ich stiess dann per Zufall
auf die Jurte.
Ich fand: "Das passt."
Die Jurte ist mobil.
Du kannst sie einpacken
und es ist wie ein Haus.
Also bestellte ich einfach eine.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich trage das Wasser.
Ich habe Wasserkanister.
Das hier ist meine Recyclingstation.
Ich hole das Wasser,
schütte es hier rein ...
Das ist
das einzige fliessende Wasser.
Dann ...
... habe ich hier ein ...
... WC mit Sickerleitung
nach draussen, um zu urinieren.
Das ist mein grösster Luxus.
Ich habe es nie bereut,
nachts rauszugehen.
Manchmal regnet es dir auf den Po
oder du siehst einen Hirsch
oder den Sternenhimmel.
Aber das ist ein Luxus,
den ich nicht missen möchte -
einfach zu urinieren.
Mit einer Sickerleitung,
die ich alle sechs Monate versetze.
Das ist
mein begehbarer Kleiderschrank ...
... und mein Büro.
Ich mache eine Ausbildung
zur SozPäd,
Erlebnis- und Sozialpädagogin,
und bin 50 % angestellt.
Das ist die Stube
mit dem Stubentisch.
Speziell
ist vielleicht der Solarstrom.
Der Teil hier wird komplett
mit Solarstrom betrieben.
Draussen hat es eine Solarzelle,
die hier reinkommt.
Das ist ein Gebastel,
es ist aber zugänglich.
Es ist auch normal, dass man
sich Dinge erleichtern will.
Man will es sich bequem machen.
Das ist auch eine Belohnung.
Man arbeitet dafür,
dass man es gemütlich hat.
Damit einem wohl ist.
Als ich hier verzichtete,
hatte ich anfangs eigentlich nichts.
Ich hatte nur den Ofen und das Bett.
Nach und nach
kamen mehr Sachen dazu.
Ich habe automatisch angefangen,
mir Dinge zu erleichtern.
Ich habe doch Dinge angeschafft:
Ich hatte einen Durchlauferhitzer,
fliessend Warmwasser ...
Ich dachte mal über eine Leinwand
nach, um ein Kino zu machen.
Absoluter Blödsinn. Das geht
wieder in dieselbe Richtung.
Es ist normal,
sich das Leben zu erleichtern.
Dann ist es zu bequem,
es wird langweilig
und
man ist nicht mehr in der Bewegung.
So verschwand
der Durchlauferhitzer wieder.
Ich habe fast ein Jahr lang
einen Platz gesucht,
an dem alles stimmte.
Ganz alleine wollte ich nicht sein.
Auf dem Hof hat es verschiedene
Leute, die hier wohnen.
Fix wohnt hier einfach die Familie.
Sie wohnen vorne im Haus.
Dann haben wir noch Auszeitleute.
Sie bleiben ein paar Wochen
oder Monate - sie kommen und gehen.
Es ist ein Joint Venture.
Wir arbeiten auf dem Hof, helfen
dort aus und leisten einen Beitrag.
Der Hof und die Gemeinschaft
profitieren davon.
Da unten hat es eine Feuerstelle
und Hühnerställe.
Das ist das Zuhause
von Jola und Marco.
Das sind Duschen und WCs.
Hier kommt man zu den Wohnwagen.
Die sind für Ferien und Auszeiten.
Alle leben selbstständig
und haben ihre eigene Küche.
Manchmal kocht jemand für alle.
Hallo.
Muss man es abstecken?
- Ich glaube schon. Das wäre cool.
Es ist halt mega nass.
Barfuss.
- Barfuss, ja.
Sollen wir es nach hinten tragen?
Es ist nicht schwer.
Stellen wir es mal hierher?
Ich hatte die Idee
für eine Biwak-Jurte.
D.h. für mich:
ohne Luxus.
Die hat keinen Filz.
Das Wichtige
ist die offene Feuerstelle.
Das stelle ich mir cool vor.
Das ist für Wanderer,
die auf den Zugerberg gehen
oder mehrtägige Touren machen.
Hier können
bis zu zwölf Personen schlafen.
Mach doch du,
ich komme nicht mehr draus.
Doch, doch, einfach rundherum.
Ich denke schon, dass das
ein Bedürfnis der Leute ist.
Sie suchen
nach alternativen Wohnformen.
Mehr mit der Natur. Mehr ...
... Verbundenheit. Vielleicht ...
... weniger Konsum.
Es gibt viele Junge aus ihrer
Generation, die das ausprobieren.
Wir haben wild
irgendwo Autos hingestellt,
Häuser besetzt
und sind reingegangen.
Daher ist es gut, was sie machen.
Sie wollen etwas installieren.
Du kannst mir den Anfang geben.
Damit irgendwann ein Recht entsteht
und die Leute das machen dürfen.
Willst du durchziehen?
Oder komm einfach.
Mhm.
Die Höhe bei Sabu
ist matchentscheidend.
Dort bei der Türe.
So rüber?
Umkehren. Die Farbe ist unten.- Ja.
Ecco.
Ja, ja, das hält es schon aus.
Wir ziehen das quasi ums Rohr herum.
Jetzt sind wir fertig für heute.
Es ist aber süss.
Ja.
Das Faszinierende daran ist,
dass du wieder in die Bewegung
kommst, wenn du verzichtest.
Es wird ja unbequem.
Du musst dafür sorgen,
dass dir warm ist,
dass es dicht ist
und du Wasser hast.
Dass du dich bewegst und dich
mit dir selber beschäftigst ...
Was brauche ist, damit mir wohl ist?
Irgendwann hast du alles gemacht -
gekocht, geholzt, eingefeuert.
Du bist vielleicht nass
und dir ist kalt,
aber du kommst nach Hause,
es ist warm
und das Essen
ist irgendwann bereit -
das ist extrem befriedigend.
Das ist ein schönes Gefühl.
Ich bin jetzt
seit sechs Jahren hier.
Das war nicht so geplant.
Aber es tat mir so gut ...
... dass sich mein ganzes Leben
zum Positiven verändert hat.
Ich habe jetzt einen Beruf,
den ich vorher nicht hatte.
Ich war auf der Suche
nach einem Job,
der mir gefällt und mich ausfüllt.
Das ergab sich so mit der Jurte.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Sie lacht. *
Ju.
Das schicke ich meinem Schatz.
Er lebt auch in einer Jurte.
Es ist lustig: Wir haben uns
auf einer Dating-App kennengelernt.
Das ging so: "Übrigens, ich lebe
in einer Jurte." "Ja, ich auch."
Ja, die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ist eins zu was weiss ich.
Das war mega süss.
Voilà. Das sieht schon cool aus.
* Ruhige Musik *
Macht Verzicht glücklich?
Über die Frage wurde auch in der
Philosophie schon viel nachgedacht
und debattiert.
Ich würde sagen: neun.
- Eine Neun? Danke.
Auch wenn die meisten von uns
nicht so radikal verzichten
wie Sandra Buchser, scheint das
im Moment ein Trend zu sein.
Man verzichtet auf Zucker, auf
Alkohol, auf tierische Produkte ...
Offenbar
verspricht man sich etwas Positives,
wenn man sagt: "Ich verzichte."
Macht Verzicht uns
zu "besseren" Menschen?
Es ist spannend, dass man sich frü-
her mit dem Besitz abheben konnte.
Wer reicher war, besass mehr
und zeigte das auch.
Das ging dann
in Kleidervorschriften über.
Im Kanton St. Gallen wurde sogar
die Grösse der Hutkrempe vorgegeben.
War man vermögender, durfte man
eine grössere Krempe haben.
Alles war normiert.
Man wollte zeigen, was man hat.
Heute kann eigentlich jede Person
anziehen, was sie will.
Also geht es mehr in eine Frage
z.B. der Ernährung.
Dass man dort verzichtet und
vegan lebt oder keinen Zucker isst.
Das ist die Möglichkeit, sich
von den anderen zu unterscheiden.
Was suchen wir im Verzicht?
Was kann uns da
potenziell glücklich machen?
Es gibt durchaus moralische Gründe
für Verzicht,
das möchte ich nicht schlechtreden.
Man sieht einfach ein, dass wir
so nicht weitermachen können,
weil wir
über unsere Verhältnisse leben.
Man sieht, dass die Umwelt-
verschmutzung und der Klimawandel
so nicht weitergehen können.
Aber abgesehen davon
ist es eine Form von Kontrolle.
Das sieht man deutlich
in der Philosophiegeschichte.
Die Philosophieschule der
Kyniker:innen sagt ganz deutlich:
"Besitze nicht,
sonst wirst du besessen."
Die Idee war, zu verzichten,
um die Kontrolle zu behalten
und sich
nicht abhängig davon zu machen,
dass andere uns mit Angeboten
verführen können.
Damit man selbstbestimmt leben kann
und sagen kann:
"Das brauche ich nicht, danke."
Ich muss das aber
immer wieder sagen:
Man darf nicht vergessen,
dass es für ganz viele Leute
in der Schweiz und weltweit sowieso
nicht "Weniger ist mehr" heisst,
sondern
weniger ist erst mal weniger.
Man kann sich glücklich schätzen,
wenn man das anders empfindet.
Viele sagen, Verzicht sei das, was
wir für die Zukunft lernen müssen.
Dass wir den Verzicht
auch positiv aufladen müssen.
Damit man es nicht als etwas sieht,
das wegfällt,
sondern als etwas,
das eine Bereicherung darstellt.
Gibt es dafür
auch philosophische Ansätze?
Was es immer gegeben hat,
ist der Versuch,
den Verzicht als Form der Kontrolle
z.B. über den Körper zu kultivieren.
All die Formen des Fastens
in den Religionsgemeinschaften z.B.
Die waren aber auch in der mittel-
alterlichen Philosophie verbreitet.
Die Askese z.B. als Versuch,
zu einer Erkenntnis zu gelangen.
Das gab es immer wieder.
Dahinter steckt die Idee,
die Vernunft oder auch die Seele
über den Körper zu stellen.
Die fleischlichen Bedürfnisse -
also Sexualität, Hunger, Schlaf -
möglichst wegzudrücken
und ganz Geist zu sein.
Diese Form der Askese wurde in der
Philosophie immer wieder gelobt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Der Verzicht auf Sex
interessiert mich als Nächstes.
Enthaltsamkeit.
Wenn ihr jetzt das Gefühl habt,
ich gehe sicher zu einer Nonne -
eben nicht.
Tina Schmidt
gab in ihrem Leben ziemlich Gas.
Ich glaube, das kann man so sagen -
wilde Partys, Glam und ganz viel Sex.
Bis zu dem Punkt, als sie sagte:
"Jetzt will ich nicht mehr."
Hallo?
Oh. Hallo. Mona.
- Hoi, Mona. Ich mache auf.
Hallo.
Ah, da bist du. Hoi, Tina.
- Hoi.
Ich komme zu dir.
- Herzlich willkommen.
Vielen Dank.
- Komm rein.
Das ist die maximale Spannung,
wenn man mit jemandem
über Verzicht auf Sex spricht.
Jetzt sehen dich alle an
und denken:
"Was hatte sie alles erlebt,
damit sie an den Punkt kam,
wo sie fand,
das sei nichts mehr für sie?"
Warum triggert uns
der Verzicht auf Sex so?
Ich denke, weil Sex
einfach eine grosse Kraft hat.
Es ist gleichzeitig etwas
sehr Kostbares und sehr Intimes.
Ich glaube,
er tangiert einfach die tiefsten ...
... Kerne der Seele.
Ich sage es mal so.
Es ist auch ein allgegenwärtiges
Thema in dieser Welt.
Würde man mich fragen,
auf was ich
freiwillig verzichten würde,
würde ich vieles vor Sex angeben.
Es ist ja auch
ein ultimativer Verzicht.
Aber, Tina, bei dir ...
Damit man überhaupt an den Punkt
kommt, wo man sagt: "Fertig!"
Du musst davor ja
ein Leben gehabt haben,
in dem Sex extrem wichtig war.
So.
Das ist eine Kiste voller Sachen.
Das bin z.B. ich.
Das war auch als Cover
auf dem "kult!"-Magazin.
Das bist du?
- Ja.
Man kann sagen, dass ich in Bern
bei allem, das lief und Szene war,
auf irgendeine Art
dabei gewesen bin.
Ich habe ja Modeshows organisiert
und lief selber als Model.
Dann gab es die grossen
Extravaganza-Modeshows ...
Du warst ein bisschen
das Berner It-Girl.
Das kann man so sagen.
Und dann halt durch Lust und Laune.
Als ich vor der Kamera stand,
kannte man mich in kürzester Zeit.
Man erkannte mich
auch auf der Strasse:
"Ah, Venus" und so.
- Das war dein zweiter Name?
Tina Venus Weiss.
- Genau, ich nannte mich Venus.
Das war mein Übername,
mein Künstlername.
* Ruhige Musik *
"Ich bin eine Westernschlampe,
die die ganze Nacht im Hinterzimmer
des Saloons eingesperrt werden muss."
Das ist Fiction.
Eine erfundene Rubrik oder Kolumne,
die es im "Soda" gab.
Da sieht man Jungs
in der Toys"R"Us-Kiste.
Okay.
- Das ist auch sehr bezeichnend.
Also, die Jungs als Spielzeug
in der Toys"R"Us-Kiste.
Ein bisschen so -
mit einem Augenzwinkern.
Die schauen so zu dir hoch.
Es war aber nur halb augenzwinkernd,
oder?
Ja. Halb echt, halb augenzwinkernd.
Das Thema ist ja Verzicht.
Verzicht ist etwas,
das du damals gar nicht kanntest.
Nein. Ich habe mir alles reingezogen
oder einfach alles gemacht ...
... und genommen,
worauf ich Lust hatte.
Ich verzichtete nicht.
Ich hatte keinen Grund dafür.
Ich verdiente gut,
konnte rumreisen, ging shoppen ...
... ging an Partys, trank Alkohol
und nahm Drogen,
wenn ich Lust hatte.
Ein Mann war immer da,
wenn ich Lust hatte ...
Du hast die Männer
eigentlich auch konsumiert.
Ja, genau. Das kann man sagen.
Ich habe eine gewisse Macht ...
... ausgespielt.
Wenn man die Kontrolle hat oder ...
Wenn du gemerkt hast,
dass sie dich wollen,
gab dir das ein Gefühl von:
"Ich kann sie haben."- Ja.
Du hast irgendwann
sogar beim "Playboy" gearbeitet
und kamst dann zurück in die Schweiz.
- Das war noch früher.
Du hast Partys organisiert,
hattest eine Agentur
und warst mega erfolgreich.
Genau in dem Moment sagst du:
"Ich höre auf."
Dann bist du in ein Zelt gezogen?
- Ja, genau.
Es stand mir wirklich bis hier.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass alles so oberflächlich war ...
... in meinem Leben.
Es war alles nur ...
... Schein. Es war nicht echt.
Hier habe ich z.B.
"simplicity" geschrieben.
Ich sehnte mich einfach irgendwie
nach einem einfachen Leben.
Hier habe ich auch bezeichnend ...
Ich ging ja von einem Haus
bzw. einer Wohnung in ein Zelt.
Von High Heels zu flachen Schuhen
oder barfuss rumlaufen.
Von Champagner zu Wasser.
Von Crevetten zu Brot.
Das zeigt so
diese Einfachheit des Lebens.
Auf was zu verzichten fiel dir
in dem Moment am schwersten?
Hm ...
Wahrscheinlich doch Sex.
In dem Sommer war noch mal was.
Obwohl ich schon gemerkt hatte,
dass es sich gegen mich drehte.
Es stimmte nicht mehr.
Ich merkte, dass ich
mich wieder reinziehen liess,
aber das
eigentlich nicht mehr wollte.
Ich hatte die Selbstbeherrschung
noch nicht ...
... um Nein zu sagen oder um ...
... wirklich zu verzichten.
Gab es einen Moment,
in dem du sagtest:
"Ab jetzt
will ich keinen Sex mehr."
Gab es den?
- Also ...
Ich sagte das nicht so.
Der Moment kam in Indien,
als ich die Bibel las.
Ich lernte dort Christen kennen
und es wies alles darauf hin,
dass ich mein Leben
Jesus anvertrauen wollte.
Dann kam der Moment,
in dem ich in den Spiegel sah
und sagte: "Ich vertraue dir
alles an, auch meine Sexualität."
"Entweder nimmst du mir die Lust,
sodass ich keine mehr habe
oder du bringst mir einen Mann,
wenn es so weit ist."
Genau so habe ich das formuliert.
Dann war das Bedürfnis auch weg.
Du wärst bereit gewesen,
dein Leben lang keusch zu leben?
Ja. Mit vollstem Herzen.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Du warst früher gar nicht gläubig,
oder?
Nein.
- Null?
Nein, null.
- Null gläubig.
Ich trat sogar aus der Kirche aus,
weil ich nichts damit am Hut hatte.
Wie ist das genau:
Hat dich der Verzicht auf dieses
ausschweifende Leben und Sex
per se glücklich gemacht?
Oder brauchte es die Religion,
um das zu kompensieren?
In dem Moment
machte mich das extrem glücklich.
Es war eine richtige Befreiung,
das alles loszuwerden.
Es wurde wirklich
zu einem Zwang für mich.
Es kam mir vor wie ein Ballast.
Ich stand ständig unter Druck.
Ich musste jemand Bestimmtes sein.
Das alles konnte ich völlig ablegen.
Das war eine grosse Befreiung
für mich.
Wie lange hast du
deine sexfreie Zeit durchgezogen?
Wie lange hast du verzichtet?
Den Verzicht
lebte ich dann vier Jahre.
Bis ich meinen Mann kennenlernte.
Und ...
- Das ist ein interessanter Moment.
Ihr hattet euch kennengelernt,
du sagtest aber immer noch:
"Ich will nichts." Wie ging das?
Wir haben
schnell über Sex gesprochen.
Nur gesprochen?
- Genau. Aber keinen gehabt.
Ich sagte mir:
"Den Nächsten, den ich kennenlerne,
soll für immer sein."
Da war auch klar, dass wir heiraten.
Es war auch für beide klar, dass
wir bis dann warten.- Wirklich?
Wenn du den Heiligen Geist hast,
hast du einfach einen anderen Geist.
Du hast jemanden, der dir hilft.
So hast du gewisse Bedürfnisse
gar nicht mehr.
Oder er hilft dabei,
beherrschter zu sein,
bewusster und achtsamer zu leben.
Dann musst du dich nicht mehr
betrinken oder exzessiv Dinge tun,
von denen du weisst,
dass sie nicht guttun.
Es gibt einen Grund dafür,
warum man das macht.
Wenn man das einigermassen
gut erklären kann,
leuchtet es vielleicht etwas ein
oder ist plausibel.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Der Verzicht auf Sex
ist ja überhaupt nichts Neues.
Barbara Bleisch, gerade in der
Philosophie, Spiritualität, Religion
kannte man das ja schon immer.
Klar.
Das hat auch verschiedene Gründe.
Einerseits die Idee,
dass die fleischlichen Lüste
immer wieder abgewertet wurden.
Völlerei, also zu viel zu essen,
wie auch Sexualität
wertete man immer wieder ab,
weil man auch den Körper abwertete.
Das eigentlich Wichtige am Menschen
ist seine Vernunft
oder die Seele
und die geistige Hingabe.
Darum vernachlässigt man
das andere lieber.
Kippt das irgendwann?
Kann Verzicht
zu viel und absurd sein?
Absurd oder schwierig wird es dann,
wenn man sich selber Schaden zufügt.
Z.B. bei Essstörungen,
beim Verzicht auf Essen.
Oder bei Leuten, die sagen,
sie könnten sich von Licht ernähren
und bräuchten sonst nichts.
Dort kippt es
in eine ungesunde Haltung.
Es ist sehr interessant,
dass die Benediktinermönche
schon früh sagten,
es sei gut zu verzichten,
es sei aber auch in Ordnung
zu konsumieren.
Wichtig sei: nichts im Übermass.
"Ne quid nimis" heisst die Regel.
Eigentlich hat man vielleicht dann
wahre Freiheit, wenn man lernt,
in einer guten Balance immer
mal wieder auf etwas zu verzichten.
Dass man es aber auch wieder
geniesst, in einem Hin und Her,
ohne sich eine neue Geissel
anlegen zu müssen -
anstatt extrem viel zu konsumieren,
im Zwang zu sein,
nichts haben zu wollen.
Wenn man so schaut, auf was in
der Fastenzeit verzichtet wird ...
Das fragt man Kinder
im Religionsunterricht:
"Auf was wollt ihr verzichten?"
Dann hört man oft:
"Keine Süssigkeiten essen."
Das Schwierigste wäre aber für
die meisten Kinder und Jugendlichen,
das digitale Gerät wegzulegen.
Ein sehr schönes Stichwort.
Der Verzicht,
den viele von uns auch nötig hätten.
Gewisse Leute machen das tatsächlich.
Daniel Hellemann gehört zu ihnen.
Er war 30, als er sagte:
"Fertig.
Ich lege das Smartphone zur Seite."
"Ich lebe ohne Handy."
Das war vor vier Jahren.
Wir schauen, wo er heute steht.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich bin Daniel Hellemann.
Ich bin 34.
Ich bin studierter Philosoph,
Landschaftsgärtner und Musiker.
Mir ist im Leben wichtig ...
... Freude zu haben ...
... und herauszufinden,
wie ich zu dieser Freude komme.
Es gibt Dinge,
auf die ich einfach verzichte.
Dadurch fühle ich mich sehr frei.
Es ist ein freiwilliger Verzicht.
Es ist ein Unterschied, wenn man
unfreiwillig verzichten muss.
Aber für mich ist das ...
Ich konzentriere mich
nicht auf den Verzicht.
Es geht darum, dass ich die Dinge
verfolgen kann, die ich will.
Denken und Handeln will
Daniel Hellemann in Einklang bringen
und zwar in allen Lebensbereichen.
Er verzichtet auf tierische Produkte
sowie auf Kaffee,
Nikotin und Alkohol.
Dieses vegane Restaurant
gehört zu einer Firma,
für die Hellemann
noch heute arbeitet.
In diesem Lokal
entschied er sich 2015 dazu,
sich von seinem Handy
zu verabschieden.
Der Tropfen, der das Fass
zum Überlaufen brachte ...
... war ein Termin.
Der war um 14 oder 14.30 Uhr.
Meine Schicht wäre eigentlich
um 14 Uhr fertig gewesen.
An diesem Samstag
war es aber so voll ...
So viele Leute wollten Glaces
und es war einfach sehr voll.
Ich kam nicht mal dazu,
nach hinten zu gehen und zu sagen,
dass ich später komme.
Als ich dann um 18 Uhr abends ...
... ans Telefon kam,
sah ich zwei, drei SMS...
... das letzte sehr unfreundlich ...
... dass ich fand, dass ich
so eine Kommunikation nicht brauche.
Ich fand das eine gute Idee.
Ich war sogar etwas eifersüchtig.
Ich möchte das Handy
auch mal loswerden.
Hier habe ich das Handy weggeworfen.
"Das nicht: Elektronikgeräte."
Sorry.
Die Handlung selber
musste aus einem Impuls entstehen.
Hätte ich überlegt,
wie ich es richtig entsorge,
hätte ich es
vielleicht nicht gemacht.
Es fühlte sich schon befreiend an.
Zwei Jahre nachdem Daniel Hellemann
sein mobiles Telefon
weggeworfen hatte,
begleitete SRF
den jungen Mann zum ersten Mal.
Im Kopf ist genug los.
Ich lasse meine Gedanken schweifen.
Ich kann gut einfach sein
und muss nicht immer etwas machen.
Der studierte Philosoph
hatte sich vorübergehend
vom Gastgewerbe getrennt.
Seine neue Herausforderung war
eine Lehre als Landschaftsgärtner.
Dank des Verzichts auf ein Handy
habe er wieder viel mehr Kontrolle
über seine Gedanken, meinte er.
Eine SMS löst dieses Kopfkino aus.
Man malt sich Geschichten aus
und überlegt,
wie das jetzt gemeint sei
und wie man etwas sagen soll.
Dabei verpufft so viel Energie.
Das ist ja die Höhe.
Ich muss nicht höher mit dem Beton.
Du gehst so durch.
Ich bewundere das.
Aber es gab schon Momente,
in denen es mühsam war.
Ich hätte ihn gerne erreicht,
er war aber unterwegs.
Das hat mich schon genervt.
Aber das sind Details.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
Die Abende im Jahr 2017
verbrachte Daniel Hellemann
mit seiner damaligen Freundin.
Sie staunte nicht schlecht,
als plötzlich Funkstille herrschte.
Ich fragte mich, was wohl los war,
warum ich nichts mehr hörte.
In einem Brief schrieb er mir,
er habe das Handy weggeworfen.
Dann
kommunizierten wir halt mit Briefen.
So war es anfangs,
als wir noch nicht zusammenwohnten.
Briefe schreiben
mag gut und schön sein.
Aber wird man ohne Handy
in der heutigen Zeit nicht asozial?
Das Handy
hat mich nie sozialer gemacht.
Also ...
Man wusste bei mir,
dass manchmal keine Antwort kommt,
ich nicht zurückrufe
oder vergesse,
etwas zu organisieren.
Aber wenn ich mal etwas mache ...
... wenn ich etwas organisiere
oder anreisse ...
... mache ich es viel seriöser.
Vier Jahre später im Sommer 2021:
Auch heute noch
trifft er lieber Menschen,
als mit ihnen zu telefonieren.
Cool. Das war ein cooler Tag.
An diesem Tag besucht er
seine Mutter und seinen Bruder.
Johann war im Lager.
Das war die Gitarre.
- Schon? Nicht deine?
Das war 2004.
Daniels Familie war nicht begeistert,
als er plötzlich sein Handy wegwarf.
Am Anfang war es schon ein ...
Es war ein bisschen wie ein Schock.
Auf einmal sagte er:
"Ich habe mein Handy entsorgt."
Puh.
Dann kam die Angst:
"Wie kann ich dich erreichen,
wenn etwas passiert?"
Eine Weile
gab ich ihm ein Kärtchen
mit meiner Telefonnummer, der seines
Vaters und seines Bruders mit,
damit er sie im Portemonnaie hat,
falls etwas passiert.
Monate später sagte er,
das Kärtchen sei ...
Dieses Kärtchen war dafür da,
falls ich ohnmächtig
unter einem Auto liege,
dass jemand anrufen
und sagen könnte:
"Ihr Sohn liegt ohnmächtig
unter einem Auto."
Das wolltest du gar nicht.
Ich wollte gar nicht davon ausgehen,
dass mir das passiert.
Der Zettel ist für den Fall,
dass etwas passiert.
Boom - dann passiert etwas.
Ich lebe lieber im Vertrauen,
dass es gut kommt.
Da hast du recht.
Vielleicht ist es auch naiv.
Besteht da auch
ein Druck von der Aussenwelt,
dass man erreichbar sein muss?
Ich denke,
dass das schon etwas mitschwingt.
Aber mittlerweile
kann ich mich gut davon absetzen.
Daniel Hellemanns
etwas eigensinnige Art
distanzierte ihn von anderen.
El martés.
Creo que estaría bien.
Dijo que iba a hacer ...
Sí. Entonces, luego te confirmo.
Der 34-Jährige sah ein, dass es
einen Richtungswechsel braucht.
Auslöser war der Umzug
in eine andere Stadt,
nachdem die Beziehung
mit seiner Freundin auseinanderging.
Am neuen Wohnort kannte er niemanden.
Damit er sich mit Freunden
jederzeit austauschen kann,
legte er sich vor einem Jahr
wieder ein Smartphone zu.
Ja, brauchen ...
Ich benutze es jeden Tag.
Es gibt selten einen Tag,
an dem ich es nicht einschalte ...
... um SMS zu checken.
Social Media aber nicht.
Ich lasse es nicht zu stark
über meine Zeit, Aufmerksamkeit,
mein Bewusstsein und Leben
bestimmen.
Ich bin sehr ...
... restriktiv
im Umgang mit dem Telefon.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Meistens liegt das kleine Tor
zur Welt unbeachtet herum.
So hat er Zeit für das,
was ihm wichtig ist.
Hoi, hoi.
- Mona.
Carla, freut mich.
- Freut mich sehr.
Du kannst auch nicht auf
dein Smartphone verzichten, oder?
Nein. Hm-m.
- Hast du heute schon gepostet?
Ja, ich habe eine Story gemacht.
Bonnieversum,
so heisst Carla Opetnik auf Insta.
Sie gewährt Einblick in ihr Leben,
das darum sehr speziell ist,
weil du dem Konsum
sehr kritisch gegenüberstehst
und das auch ...
... bis zum Letzten
konsequent auslebst.
Wir sehen, wie das aussieht:
Ich bin Carla, ich bin 27
und wohne mitten in der Stadt Zürich
an der Langstrasse.
Ich mache momentan die Matura
und bin ursprünglich Schneiderin.
Ich lebe minimal waste.
Minimal waste heisst für mich,
möglichst
auf alles Unnötige zu verzichten -
sprich,
ich kaufe nichts mit Plastik,
ich schlürfe meine Drinks
nicht mit Strohhalmen ...
Ich hatte anfangs
mega Respekt davor,
Dinge wie Zahnpasta und Deo
auszutauschen.
Anstatt
einer konventionellen Zahnpasta
nutze ich Kokosnussöl
und Aktivkohle.
Kokosnussöl ist antimikrobakteriell
und antifungal.
Es ist mega toll für alles.
Die Aktivkohle
wirkt ganz zart abrasiv.
Als Rouge
nutze ich ein Randenpulver.
Wenn ich mich schminken will,
streiche ich mir das auf die Backe.
Im Sommer ist das Deo etwas mühsam.
Kokosnussöl schmilzt ja
ab einem gewissen Punkt.
Wenn es so heiss ist sowieso.
Aber es geht um das Natron,
das im Deo ist.
Das verhindert,
dass sich Bakterien bilden.
Man nimmt einfach
ein bisschen raus ...
... und streicht es
unter die Achseln.
Das funktioniert
wie ein normales Deo,
bekämpft aber nicht die Symptome,
das Stinken,
sondern die Ursache.
Es hat keine Bakterien,
die dann stinken können.
Es gibt immer Dinge,
die man noch von vorher hat.
Bevor man damit angefangen hat.
Ich schätze,
es geht ein bis eineinhalb Jahre,
bis du alles ausgephast hast,
bevor man
alle Produkte verbraucht hat.
Das ist anfangs mega mühsam, weil
man gefühlt nicht vorwärtskommt.
Aber man muss wie über den Berg -
das dauert mega lange.
Das ist aber okay.
Ich kaufe alles offen ein, bringe es
in meinen Säckchen nach Hause
und fülle es in meine Gläser.
Somit habe ich keine Verpackung,
also keinen Abfall.
Wo der Abfall sonst ist,
stehen bei mir Küchenmaschinen.
Es ist lustig:
Die Leute gehen automatisch unter
die Spüle und suchen den Abfall.
Wenn ich dann sage,
sie könnten es dort ins Glas legen,
sind sie jeweils sehr irritiert.
Ich habe keinen Abfall mehr
bzw. nur noch ein Glas.
Das ist gut so. Ich will das nicht.
Das ist rund ein Monat Abfall.
Vieles, das hier drin ist,
ist Recyclingabfall.
Das ist z.B. vom Zucker.
Linsen.
Ab und zu gönnt man sich Linsen.
Dann ein Stückchen Holz.
So.
Hier habe ich ...
... ca. siebenmal vergessen
zu sagen,
dass ich den Eiskaffee oder Eistee
ohne Strohhalm und Chichi möchte.
Strohhalme nerven mich einfach mega.
Ich nehme sie mit und denke dann:
"Ich brauche es
wenigstens noch mal."
Dann ist es nicht nur one way.
Das ist eine Bodylotion,
die ich noch von vorher hatte.
Ich komme nicht darum herum,
die Dinge abzuwägen und diese ...
... Kleberchen zu haben.
Ausser ich hole es beim Bauern.
Aber ich habe kein Auto und Bauern
sind nicht sehr gut erschlossen.
Dadurch ist es wie ...
Um gewisse Dinge kommt man nicht rum
und das ist okay.
Eine andere Option wäre schön,
aber ...
... sich deswegen zu stressen
ist nicht nötig.
Die Tonne ist ein Kompost.
Wenn du dir den Abfall
in der Schweiz anschaust,
sind ca. 30 % von dem, was wir
in die Kehrichtverbrennung schicken,
Essen.
Das ist ein Wurmkompost.
Ich nehme noch kurz
das Element hier weg.
Da bewegt es sich.
Das Ziel ist eigentlich,
dass nichts
aus deiner Lebenszeit zurückbleibt.
Wenn ich mal gehe,
dass alles mit mir ...
... vergehen kann.
Wie ich zu Erde werde,
wird alles andere zu Erde.
Es ist jeden Tag
ein bisschen struggle dabei.
Aber es macht
auch so viel zufriedener.
Ich weiss:
I'm not part of this shit.
* Entspannte Musik *
487 g.
(Durchsage)
Abfahrt 13.06 Uhr, Gleis 3.
ICE Regio 37
nach Lenzburg, Aarau, Basel ...
Das ist jetzt ein Problem.
Sonst würde ich sagen,
ich hole dir einen Coffee-to-go.
Das würdest du aber nicht annehmen,
oder?
Wenn du ihn schon geholt hättest
und damit dastehst,
würde ich ihn nicht verschmähen.
- Ja.
Meistens habe ich einen Becher
oder irgendein Gefäss dabei.
Willst du oben oder unten?
- Spielt keine Rolle.
"Part of this shit" -
was ist denn der Shit?
Dass wir unsere Ressourcen
behandeln, als wären sie endlos.
Dass wir das Gefühl haben,
alles müsse immer wachsen,
wir bräuchten mehr
und müssten anhäufen.
Wir müssen wieder lernen
zu teilen und zusammenzuleben,
anstatt einen Massenindividualismus
zu leben.
* Entspannte Musik *
Wir besuchen eine Person,
auf die du dich schon sehr freust,
weil das etwas Clash of Cultures ist.
Hausi Leutenegger,
ein Selfmade-Millionär -
eine Person,
die eher auf grossem Fusse lebt.
Ob ihr euch etwas zu sagen habt
in Sachen Verzicht ...- Let's see.
Er hat gut lachen: Hausi Leutenegger,
geschätzte 200 Mio. Fr. schwer.
Wohnsitze am Genfersee,
auf den Kanarischen Inseln
und angemeldet
im steuergünstigen Freienbach.
Wir sind am Genfersee, in Rolle.
Das ist mein Sommersitz.
* Entspannte Musik *
Willkommen bei mir zu Hause.
Hausi Leutenegger, danke, dass wir
nach Gran Canaria kommen dürfen.
Geil.
Ich habe mir gesagt:
"Ich versuche alles,
um erfolgreich zu sein."
1960 -
Hausis Lebensthema ist Anerkennung.
Ich wohnte
in einem Dorf am Bichelsee.
Ich war ein Niemand in diesem Dorf.
Das war der Grund, warum ich
verschwand und nach Genf ging.
Ich fing natürlich ohne Geld an.
Ich ging mit 100 Fr. nach Genf.
Dann gründeten wir die Firma.
Ein Montageunternehmen.
Dann explodierte es.
Es gab riesige Beträge.
Es gab eine Explosion
für die Raiffeisenbank Bichelsee.
Eine Explosion.
Als ich 30 wurde, sagte ...
... mein Treuhänder: "Ich muss dir
etwas sagen. Du bist Millionär."
Da sagte ich: "Noch mal.
Ich will es noch mal hören."
Ich wusste es schon.
Ich konnte gut rechnen.
Der Bauschlosser aus dem Thurgau
wird 1972
Olympiasieger im Viererbob ...
... spielt in über 30 Filmen mit ...
Ich töte niemanden,
wenn es nicht sein muss.
Moment, raus.
... und ist ein erfolgreicher
Unternehmer, Frauenheld und Sunnyboy.
Welches ist es wohl?
- Ich denke, oben hinten.
Ich hätte es mir fast noch
etwas grandioser vorgestellt.
Ja, ich auch.
- Aber ...
Ui.
- Ich bin geimpft.
Du bist geimpft.
Ihr könnt reinkommen,
mir die Hand schütteln,
mich küssen - ich bin geimpft.
Sehr gut.
- Ich bin getestet. Hausi.
Wunderschön.
Thurgauer müssen zusammenhalten.
Wie geht es?
- Wie heisst sie?- Carla.
Das ist Hausi Leutenegger.
Ihr dürft euch duzen.
Ihr könnt mir alle Du sagen.
Die ganze Schweiz sagt mir Du.
Ich bin Hausi für die Schweizer.
- Super.- Sehr gut.
Ich heisse euch willkommen.
- Vielen Dank.
Champagner? Nein, danke.
- Es hat auch Weisswein.
Sagt, was ihr wollt.
Ich mag Süssmost
lieber als Champagner.- Gut.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl. Mhm.
... rund ein Monat Abfall.
Vieles, das hier drin ist,
ist noch Recyclingabfall.
Da bewegt es sich.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
- Siehst du.
Sind die lebendig?
- Ja.
Die armen Teufel.
(Video) I'm not part of this shit.
Hausi ...
- Wenn alle so leben würden,
würde die Welt überschnappen -
ganz klar.
Dann würde die Welt überschnappen.
Aber es ist eine Einstellungssache.
Warum würde die Welt überschnappen,
wenn alle so leben?
Dann würde die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen.
Du verlierst so viel Zeit damit.
Wenn ein Bankdirektor so was macht,
fällt die Börse morgen zusammen.
Carla, was sagst du dazu?
Ja. Ja.
Ich finde das ziemlich lustig,
weil du dir theoretisch
das Essen aus dem Zero-Waste-Laden
nach Hause liefern lassen kannst.
Hausi, könntest du dir vorstellen,
auch so zu leben?
Nein. Ich bin in einem Alter,
in dem ich nicht darauf achten muss.
Und ich bin bescheiden aufgewachsen.
Wir lebten sehr bescheiden.
Wir waren acht Kinder.
Wir mussten
um unsere Existenz kämpfen.
"Vogel friss oder stirb."
Am Bichelsee schwimmen zu gehen
kostete 20 Rp.
Das Geld dafür hatten wir nicht.
Wenn das Wetter schön war,
mussten wir Äpfel zusammenlesen
oder unserem Vater
beim Heuen helfen.
In jungen Jahren
musste ich auf alles verzichten.
Darum hast du gesagt: "Das
will ich nie mehr in meinem Leben."
Genau das sagte ich:
"Wenn ich heirate, will ich das
meinen Kinder nicht antun."
Diese junge Generation ist in anderen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.
Können sie darum
einfacher verzichten?
Sie hatten ja schon alles.
Es tut ihnen gut, zu verzichten.
Sie sind mit allem aufgewachsen.
Sie hatten alles.
Dann ist es doch noch schwieriger,
zu verzichten.
Nein, dann ist es wie eine Sportart.
Spannend.
- Das ist Sport.
Einer macht einen Marathon,
ein anderer kriecht den Berg hoch,
und sie machen das.
- Ist das so?
Ich sehe es nicht als Sport.
Aber es ist sicher so,
dass ich so lebe, weil ich das kann.
Weil ich das Privileg dazu habe.
Aber das hättest du auch.
Ich habe eine Frage.
- Ja?
Willst du heiraten?
Hast du einen Lebenspartner?
Was sagt der dazu? Macht er mit?
- Meistens, ja.
Alle Achtung.
Den musst du schnell heiraten.
Carla, ich frage mich:
Haben wir es einfach mit einem
Generationenunterschied zu tun?
Das ist die Generation Boomer
und die neue sagt,
man müsse Verzicht lernen.
Unserer Generation ist bewusst,
dass die Zukunft nicht endlos ist
und nicht alles auf wirtschaftlichem
Wachstum aufbauen kann.
Wir müssen erkennen,
dass wir mehr Menschen sind
und wir müssen lernen zu teilen.
Und Dinge zusammen zu haben,
anstatt alles selber zu besitzen.
Hausi,
du hast vier verschiedene Wohnsitze.
Vier, fünf Stück. Ich wohne überall.
- Genau.
Du wohnst überall
und geniesst das Leben.
Es ist krass:
Wir hatten Generationen -
meine
wahrscheinlich eingeschlossen -,
die relativ sorglos
mit den Ressourcen umgingen.
Wir leben alle im Überfluss.
Jetzt kommt eine jüngere Generation,
die weiss:
Das können wir uns nicht leisten.
Macht einen das auch wütend?
Hey ...
Das darf einen
nicht zu wütend machen.
Aber ...
- Natürlich macht es etwas wütend.
Aber man muss nach vorne schauen.
Man muss schauen,
was für Lösungen es gibt,
anstatt wütend auf seine Eltern
oder auf Menschen zu sein,
die es halt nicht interessiert.
Sonst verschwendet man
extrem viel Energie mit etwas ...
... das gar nichts bringt.
- Wie muss Verzicht sein,
damit man
etwas Positives zurückerhält?
Wenn du weisst, dass du hinter
deinen Entscheidungen stehen kannst,
dass du mit dem, was du konsumierst,
gute Projekte unterstützt
und dass keine Kinderhände
an deinen Kleidern gearbeitet haben,
dass deine Philosophie mit dem
übereinstimmt, was du machst.
Ich möchte eines sagen:
Ich habe viel Geld
für meine Angestellten eingesetzt.
Ich musste ihnen die Sicherheit ge-
ben, dass sie ihren Zahltag kriegen.
Das Geld war nicht für mich alleine.
Ich hatte
immer eine Verantwortung ...
... für 1'000 bis 1'500 Personen,
die jeden Monat
pünktlich ihren Zahltag kriegten.
Ich stand immer unter Stress.
"Der hat ein geiles Leben, er hat
eine Villa auf Gran Canaria ..."
Aber ich hatte immer Verantwortung
für meine Mitarbeiter.
Auf diese Verantwortung
verzichtest du gerne, oder?
Die möchte ich nie mehr. Dafür
würde ich auf alles verzichten.
Ich wäre lieber Bauer geworden ...
... und hätte Kühe usw.,
einen Bauernbetrieb halt,
als das ganze Leben
eine solche Verantwortung
auf den Schultern zu tragen.
Man ist wohlhabend,
aber die Gedanken waren nie frei.
Vielen Dank, Carla Opetnik
und Hausi Leutenegger.
Mir bleibt von der Frage
"Macht Verzicht glücklich?",
dass es sich lohnt,
mal genauer hinzuschauen,
was wir im Leben
eigentlich alles haben.
Seien das Gegenstände, Menschen
oder Dinge, die wir machen.
Was davon
macht uns tatsächlich glücklicher?
Und was machen wir einfach, weil wir
noch nie darüber nachgedacht haben?
Ich bin sicher,
auch Sie nehmen viele Fragen mit.
Einen schönen Abend.
Danke fürs Interesse.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021